Actually, I'm kind of wondering if I close my eyes and type on the phone how accurate it can be. Right now Wren's working.
I'm gonna send him a text message, ask him how the project's going.
We just get one last look at this keyboard here. I could also really type something offensive
I have no idea what's going to happen. Here we go ready and...
So today we have something super super special in this box. This has been sitting in the studio for the last 48 hours
burning a hole in the back of my mind.
I've been just waiting to open this. I kind of want to say this kind of spiraled out of control a little bit.
My computer in my workstation in the studio kind of got turned into a shelf.
With my absence my "personal" desk and computer
got turned over to Christian the desk itself just became a junk pile.
Leaving me in a position where I didn't really have a desk or a workstation to use. I ended up taking the sound
workstation, the one that's in the back here, typically reserved for sound editing and mixing etc.
However a lot of other people didn't like how I was always using this communal workstation
and I started thinking I think it's about time
We call up Puget and see if we can figure out what my next work stations gonna look like.
After years using a computer and typing I've never actually really learned how to type without looking at the keyboard
I mean I'm pretty good
I know where stuff is not just instinctually, but if I close my eyes and type on the phone how accurate it can be.
-That's what autocorrect is for though right?
-That's what autocorrect is for, and apparently people have said the iPhone has really solid autocorrect. I know it corrects things sometimes
when you don't want to but for the most part it's pretty good. Right now Wren's working. I'm gonna send him a text message
I could also really type something offensive. I've no idea what's going to happen. Here we go ready and
How's it going
-Wren did you get a text from Niko?
-Hey Wren Deke assesses KFClinic
-Wait what?
It's a glitch hold on I gotta text you something.
-What does that even mean, Niko?
-Are you sleeping again?
... and send.
-Hey dude,  his age thing's going on that excabachs
Dude I'm just trying to send a coherent text message to my friend. Dude, Jake's looking at me like I'm crazy.
I'm gonna send Jake message to clear things up.
Hey Jake I am
Trying to type without
looking at my phone.
Send.
-Hey Jake u m trying to those sit hith looking gee my phone
Let me respond back to Niko quick.
-Okay, but you gotta no eyes.
Okay, that sounds good I'll talk to you dnnn
So wait let me get let me get this straight. I'm supposed to write a text message to you with my eyes closed?
It's already...
-That's what autocorrect is for
-Let's find out
You broke it!
It's like really broken now!
God I hate this thing.
God I hate this thing... So much!
Hey Niko comma I think the drone video is doing great exclamation point.
-What are you doing? this ain't no voice to text.
-The drone
video is going to be
really cool in the future when we're able to finally finish it and release it
to the world for everyone to enjoy
Exclamation point send.
The drone video is going to be really cool in undatan when
we are able to renault C finish, and lah I have ooold think I would pho be honeth on Facebook joy
and a smiley face.
This is gonna get weird when some of those weird words that you guys sometimes type go into your
Auto memory thing where there's those weird words you don't want people know that you type often show up.
-Niko.
This is funny and all but I think we need to raise the stakes.
-How do you wanna raise the stakes?
-I'm gonna point this nerf gun at Shonduras' head
and it's up to you to warn him to turn around.
If he reads that message and he doesn't know to turn around I'm firing this nerf gun into his back.
-Okay, here we go.
I play a specific role in this studio when it comes to the things I am best at:
3d work I do a lot of After Effects work.
But once again most computers can handle that, anyone can do VFX.
The difference is that I also do a lot of the audio work in this studio.
I have a big music and audio background, so I decided on top of making a good generalist visual effects computer workstation,
what can we do to this machine that makes it a little more audio oriented?
40-50 audio layers? What's the best workstation I can use to get like low latency, really fast load times, and
have the best audio working experience? We've been talking with Eric Brown over at Puget systems
and he's been a huge help because the computers and the workstations they put together are some of the most
professionally created machines and workstations in the world. These guys have created workstations
for NASA related activities among other things so let's take a look, finally.
Get out of here! >:(
Hey Shaun, Nick is
standing behind you, and if you don't
turn... oh, no I spelled that wrong... around now you
will get shot.
I should just texted him "turn around Shaun" all right and send.
Why'd I get shot for checking my phone!?
I can't even show the camera this because it's inappropriate. Why'd you type this?
-So I told Niko that I was gonna stand behind you with a nerf gun and if he didn't warn you successfully
-He didn't warn me at all!
There's not a single word of warning except for flu. He wrote the word flu twice.
-Behind is in there
-Can you read that message for us with excepting all the swear words?
-Blank gain Nick is
Sivan Qing gun behind gah if flu song dubs fubbed bid
flew bad ZFKF.
How did I not know?
-Man, you're responsible for your friend's nerf death.
-I know. I guess if our lives are on the line
I'll at least make sure I have my eyes open
on my phone, so I can text things.
This is hard. You know sometimes
It's accurate like Jake almost got it through, but it's harder than I think autocorrect is maybe not
as all powerful as I think it is. Also I think I just screwed that up.
-Dude somehow I managed to put in an emoji.
-Hey, you ready? I'm responding.
Kay, get my fingers in the right place.
-Eyes closed.
Shaun's like really blind this is what actual blind people look like.
-Dude you're writing a novel over there.
-I haven't tried to use like exclamation marks and stuff, hitting send.
-Thanks, Inc go do ou get so rig that awesome merch be us the link in the bio VB?
I was just asking where you got that awesome merch and if the link was in the bio!
That was pretty close! I text a lot.
-Wren you have something to say?
-I just got a text message...
If you like our sgshgzl consider sync diving
Sync diving?
Is that supposed to be subscribing?
-Yeah, if you like our videos consider subscribing!
-Consider sync diving!
I printed out the parts list. What started out as a really good audio workstation turned out to be the best
computer in the studio by like triple. So I better get some damn good use out of this thing.
The instructions are just constantly flip each box upside down.
Do you hear that sound?
(peeling plastic off computer case)
It's like toothpaste coming out.
-Wow this is one spicy case.
gosh
Each time I pull up this list, I like I get lightheaded.
This is what a $9,000 PC looks like.
-What? That's way more than the one I use!
It's not a competition, Wren. Oh, okay, I opened the wrong part.
-Dude the laser engraving on the front is like a really nice touch.
MWAH
-MWAH
-MWAH MWAH MWAH
-MUHH
-TEN CORE?!
What makes a good audio workstation and also a good VFX generalist workstation?
How do we combine these together? Well, let's load it up with a beefy processor, a beefy GPU.
That covers the visual effects in right there.
But for audio low latency and drawing lots of files, things like that. We decided to actually
wire together a cool little SSD cache, effectively.
Inside of here we have our operating system, we have our storage, but we're also using another SSD here
that is exclusively going to be for the cache. Basically the cache is where applications
put their temporary files. Each time you preview a file or something like that
it's saving the previews and all the the cache, the memory, to this one specific ultra-fast drive and
just overall, just makes using any application that has to sling big files around incredibly speedy.
Ten core processor. We have a gigabyte X299 motherboard, Intel i9 7900X 10-core processor. i9!
We have 128 GB of RAM.
DDR4, solid. 1080 Ti GPU. 2 terabyte SSD for the operating system.
-Just take a deep breath man.
-These are huge. We are using a 1 TB M.2 SSD drive as the core OS drive that holds the operating system.
We also have another 2 terabytes SSD which will be our general storage and applications drive.
And then we have one more 2 terabyte SSD drive, which is just going to be for caching files.
It's got a cool power supply thousand watts. That's basically it.
This is the classiest thing of all. Each time they ship you a machine
they also include a binder and inside that binder
not only is it starts with a thank you letter
But they lists all your software serial keys for Windows 10. Don't look at that.
They have the MAC address, all the technical information. They have photos of the exact system they
sent you for quality control purposes. They also have thermal imaging of the computer idling and at a full load
You can see that there. A full list of specs, motherboard connections,
troubleshooting guide for this machine specifically, activation help, a build checklist,
which lists everything that was done to the machine and at exactly what time and who did it.
Done by Houston on 9/22/17 at 2:42
This isn't some like run-of-the-mill this isn't like something out of the factory
that's like kind of booted once or twice and sent off. This ain't no Alienware.
-Look at how that fits perfectly.
-I know. So this is your new office now, this is where you're gonna be set up.
-I moved from here to here. I guess next to the closet?
Sure. I mean honestly, I don't like this spot anyway, it's in the corner
I can't see out there, can't talk to anyone.
We're gonna raise the stakes here Niko.